now what would happen if you starved
yourself
for seven days it sounds real scary and
some people associated starving with
dying but in reality
it would be the healthiest thing that
you can do for your body
in fact out of all the things you can do
for your health i don't think there's
anything that could compare
with what you could do
with just
fasting now i'm going to get into the
difference between fasting and starving
in a minute but if it is true that out
of all the things fasting can create
more health than anything else then by
logic it must also be true that frequent
eating will create the most health
problems that you could have and i think
that is true i mean take a look at how
many people eat frequently three square
meals snacks between meals grazing at
night
i think the majority of the population
is literally eating constantly
i mean i remember in practice there were
people that would be eating
so frequently they had to even get up in
the middle of the night and consume some
food or they would have blood sugar
issues i didn't know back then that low
blood sugar problems
hypoglycemia
could be easily corrected
by not eating so frequently i was under
this assumption this false assumption
that you had to eat to
prevent hypoglycemia and there were just
certain people that had blood sugar
issues and that's the way that you have
to handle it in fact people have
hypoglycemia or low blood sugar could
easily correct it by doing intermittent
fasting all right so how long could a
person live without water well about
three to five
plus days the person who took the world
record at surviving without food and
water lasted about 18 days but it wasn't
a hundred percent uh he was thrown in a
jail and people forgot about him and the
only thing that he survived on as far as
liquids was the condensation on the cell
wall i really don't know how much water
there is when you have condensation but
it's probably not that much but he
lasted 18 days and someone did find him
so he didn't die
and as far as someone living without
food the person who was in the guinness
book of world records lasted
382 days without eating any food
now he drank water tea coffee he took
vitamins electrolytes and he even
consumed yeast for his b vitamins and
for some amino acids a lot of people
don't realize that
nutritional yeast is loaded with b
vitamins amino acids and trace minerals
so he lost a total of
276 pounds which is 125 kilograms he
started at 456 pounds and he went all
the way down to 180 pounds so we fasted
for over a year what you have to realize
is the average person who is not
overweight
has enough fat calories on them
survive quite some time they have about
a hundred thousand calories
so if a person roughly weighs 150 pounds
and they're burning between one thousand
to two thousand calories per day they
have enough fat fuel to last about 67
days without food now what happens when
you stop eating
is that there's some initial discomfort
between one and two days you might be a
little bit hungry because you're not
used to it you haven't adapted to fat
quite yet you might feel a little bit
weaker but if you had some salt
electrolytes with potassium you wouldn't
be fatigued but very shortly by the
second and third day you would find that
your hunger would start to go away you
will no longer have an appetite now i
want to talk about the difference
between
starving your body
and fasting because a lot of the side
effects from starvation occur when
you're not consuming nutrients so when
you're doing fasting and the type of
fasting i'm going to recommend you're
drinking enough fluids you're taking
your nutrients you're just not having
anything of substantial calories now the
body will start to starve
when it runs out of fat if you have
enough fat you're not going to starve
because your body is going to live off
the fat as the backup fuel now when
you're starving you have no more fat so
the body is going to go after its muscle
it's going to eat up its muscle for fuel
and it's also going to eat up its organs
but when you're fasting
you're going to just purely burn fat
this is its purpose i think just people
have not tapped into this because
there's so much food available in fact
when you're fasting your body protects
its muscles this is called protein
sparing your demand for amino acids in
repair goes way down your body becomes
very very efficient at what it does so
the main fuel with fasting is fat
calories the main fuel when you're
starving is your own muscle calories and
organ calories
now when you're starving your appetite
is just incredibly intense you're going
to be hungry for everything and you'll
pretty much eat almost anything but when
you're fasting you have no appetite
because you are eating when you're not
eating you're eating your own fat
reserve and it's a clean energy and you
crave nothing now with starving you're
going to be very apathetic okay
but
when you're fasting
your mood is
greatly elevated your emotions are
enhanced you feel euphoric so if you
haven't seen uh one of my videos which
i'll i'll put at the end of this video
there is a gentleman who decided to
end his life he wanted to commit suicide
everything was going downhill he had
diabetes he had all sorts of issues so
he
went in his room and he stopped eating
for three days and it rebounded on him
because he started feeling better
emotionally physically to the point
where he started to go online and search
about fasting and it turned his life
completely around i'll share that video
in a little bit like i said before
fasting is hands down
the most important thing you can do for
your health now when you're starving you
have atrophy of the muscles but when
you're fasting you get a huge spike of
growth hormone in fact if you compare
high intensity exercise with fasting
with exercise you're only going to get
like a spike of growth hormone by 700
percent
but with fasting you can get a spike up
growth hormone by 2 000
and growth hormone is all about
muscle synthesis and growing muscles and
preserving muscles and with starving
you're going to be highly irritable
you're going to be grouchy just like you
see with people that have low blood
sugars but with fasting
people become very very
pleasant they have a great sense of
well-being they're very nice to be
around they're not angry people as i'm
going to share in this success story at
the end this man was very very angry all
the time and he just could not believe
how
uh that changed when he started doing
fasting it's actually quite remarkable
now with starving there's a major
cognitive decline your brain starts to
shrink you start losing focus you start
losing
memory you start losing concentration
you can't concentrate but with fasting
you have what's called neurogenesis you
start growing
new nerve cells you start growing a new
brain all sorts of very very cool things
like the brain neurotrophic factor
starts increasing and you become sharper
you have a better memory you have a lot
more focus you become a lot more
creative more aware i mean out of all
the things you can do what could come
even close to creating these amazing
effects
as compared to fasting i mean it's just
mind-blowing the positive impact that
fasting can have
on every single part of your body now
with starving you're going to be weak
you're going to be tired but with
fasting you stay strong and you have
tons of energy i mean a good way to know
if you're taking the right amount of
electrolytes b vitamins nutrition and
trace minerals while you're fasting
is that you still have a lot of energy
during the day and you can still
maintain the same level of exercise
performance
as you do when you're eating that is a
good indicator to know that you're
taking the right nutrition now with
starving you have massive nutritional
deficiencies okay
you start having deficiencies in b1
that's called beriberi severe severe
side effects from that
vitamin b3 pellegra your skin starts to
get all rashy and scaly
a lot of problems then we have scurvy
right no vitamin c you start becoming
extremely fatigued you start getting
bleeding gums
your connective tissue falls apart your
joints fall apart and then a vitamin d
deficiency rickets so this is where you
have
severe bone pain osteoporosis
you have very very weak bones not to
mention a severe problem with your
immune system you become susceptible to
viruses and bacteria and infections
very easily but with fasting your immune
system starts to become very very strong
in fact you start developing more
antibodies you start becoming resistant
to viruses and bacterial infection the
stem cells in your bone marrow start to
rebuild the immune system your body
starts going into this
self-regenerative recycling mode it's
called autophagy where it takes all this
damaged the proteins that are clogging
everything up in your brain and your
arteries and your eyes and it starts to
recycle that into new cells so you start
becoming younger by recycling the old
waste and
with autophagy you are cleaning out old
dormant
viruses and bacteria
i mean how cool is that now with fasting
your antioxidant
networks are
improved so when you don't eat your body
makes more antioxidants wow what a
survival mechanism with fasting your
insulin becomes more sensitive and if
you had a slow metabolism your
metabolism starts becoming stronger and
faster if you have metabolic syndrome
where you have high blood pressure that
tends to go away also with metabolic
syndrome you have a belly fat you see if
you ate nothing for seven days you would
lose at least 4.9 pounds of actual fat
now when you're fasting your microbiome
the good bacteria in your gut
start to become very diversified they
start to live longer and you start
enhancing different strains
of friendly microbes so you strengthen
not just your microbiome but the
intestinal wall in your gut as well so
if you have leaky gut you have
permeability issues that all improves if
you have allergies those improve if you
have gut inflammation that improves all
inflammation in the body tends to go
bye-bye with fasting and that relates to
autoimmune diseases arthritis bursitis
tendinitis
anything related to inflammation and
pain if you have pain that goes away too
the detox
enzymes in your liver start to become
strengthened so your ability to detox
improves your cells ability to resist
stress
increases so your cellular tolerance of
stress improves so let's say for example
you have cancer and you have to go on
chemo or radiation your cells resist
that toxicity more when you do fasting
when you fast you take someone from
being sympathetic dominant in flight of
fight mode to more parasympathetic
dominant where you're calm and you're
more relaxed and
to put the icing on the cake no pun
intended when you fast you kill off
cancer cells like crazy if you have a
tumor the tumor starts shrinking out of
anything you can do for cancer fasting
is the most powerful thing you can do
the only catch-22 with doing fasting for
cancer is that you have to have some fat
in your body to really do it effectively
but there are some things you can do if
you are thinned or frail and i'm going
to put that link down below related to
cancer so i hope i convinced you to do
more fasting not just intermittent
fasting but periodic prolonged fasting
you just have to make sure you take
enough nutrients while you fast i'll put
those links down below but here's that
video that i mentioned about the guy who
tried to take his own life
and just stop eating for three days
check it out
you